so we did everything we could to
elongate this fire but nothing was
working okay there was only there was
only so much we could ration out this
firewood i think i think the last log
lasted like us like for a full hour
there's only so many like tiny little
twigs you find on the on the paddock
right there where it's like yes this
will do yeah yeah i remember there was a
tree next to where i pissed and i like i
picked up the leaves right and i'm just
like okay these dead leaves these these
are work and they gave us like like a
micro second of heat and that that felt
like that felt like to me at the time
like a full 10 minutes right yeah we
start we start like using the [ __ ]
uh
we started using like the beer packaging
so it was like we had like we had like
all the cardboard packaging and we were
like we went from using the beer
cardboard to like rationing it as like
as like a as like a big burst of heat
because that would give us like a nice
big bust that he like a good five
seconds we'd all crowd around and we
were like all right boys when do we do
the next one when do we use the next one
and we eventually just can't wait any
longer
we eventually just didn't even drink the
beers but we just still unwrapped and
wrapped the base with all the packaging
so we could use it as fuel but uh we
should have recycled but instead we
needed heat yeah yeah but uh eventually
eventually uh we ran out of things to
burn i know guys i ran out of resources
i put garnet in the fire
unfortunately
um so eventually that was when we
realized we had had to go to bed um and
uh so we packed everything up and at
this point it was maybe around minus one
minus two it's starting to get pretty
[ __ ] it's it was starting to get
pretty really cold uh yeah but it was
like negative degrees um for you
americans that's a negative from the
boiling from the freezing point of water
so i don't know what the freezing point
of water is in fahrenheit but it was it
was below that below 32. why is it 32.
it's 32 fahrenheit is zero degrees
celsius oh okay i didn't know that i
think i did not know that it's 30
something i'm pretty sure yeah 3.8 is
one degree celsius yeah 32 32 is zero so
it was like maybe like 28 yeah
fahrenheit
um and this is when we came to realize
how cold it really was going to be uh
without even like a piddly little fire
to uh heat us up and i remember me and
connor uh went into our tent first so me
and connor slept with nabi in his turn
and joey and luke slept in another tent
and everyone else slept in the third
tent
um and i remember connor jumping in
right kind of jumping in and just
realizing how flimsy and thin
his sleeping bag was yeah i literally
had gotten a raincoat that had just been
fashioned into it was like it didn't it
didn't have any padding or anything and
i was like this is what i get yeah
ordering the only available sleeping bag
on amazon for the next day delivery yeah
because i was like it was like 20 bucks
yeah because i remember i think the
warmest coat you have by far is your
drip jacket yeah and this was the one
time in the past month i think i've seen
you without the drip jackets where it
would have been very very useful
the reason i didn't bring it right is
because we were going to be burning a
lot of [ __ ] and i was like i didn't want
to get this this nice jacket that i paid
way too much money for super smoky and i
was probably gonna be messy too it was
messy i dropped condiments everywhere i
was like i'm gonna just i'm just leaving
yeah yeah i wish i did yeah but yeah so
connor like [ __ ] gets in the sleeping
bag and steven realizes that this is not
going to be [ __ ] warm enough at all
and he just gets over and he's like gone
gone i give you permission to cuddle me
we are cuddling tonight i'm like we
don't need to cuddle we don't need to
cuddle and then i get into the tent and
i realize
[ __ ] we're gonna need to cuddle tonight
connor
i i take off my jackets like as fast as
possible and then and then i try to like
get in the sleeping bag and i zip myself
up i'm [ __ ] freezing and i like i saw
like like two caterpillars next to each
other like [ __ ] cuddling with each
other and then that still isn't warm
enough so i i kind of realized pretty
soon that i have to sleep with my jacket
on because even with my jacket off it's
not going to be warm enough um luckily
at this point i think we were pretty
drunk right yeah i must say it was very
funny from the other 10 when all i could
hear was god cuddle me now get closer to
me i was freezing i'll be the small
spoon you be the large spoon cuddle me
now listen i've seen enough bad girls to
know what to do yeah i knew what you did
drink my piss now
it's for survival god don't ask but i
fashioned my jeans into a piss filter
i'm already drinking the water you can
go next i've already pissed in a gun i i
was i think i was wearing like maybe six
layers i i had fashioned my my spare
t-shirt and put it around my neck as a
neck warmer
yeah because it was so cold okay what
was the coldest part of your body what
was the part that was hurting
my feet yeah it's the feet for me yeah i
was wearing the family mask socks that
didn't help
so one time i was also wearing my family
martial
i was i was rocking a pair of jeans it
was fine my legs were fine honestly that
wasn't a problem i was wearing a long
sleeve thin shirt with a big thick
jumper yeah and i went to bed using my
coat as the pillow because i didn't have
a pillow yeah woke up at like 2 a.m i
think so i was too cold and i put the
jacket on it didn't really help much um
because by that point i was already too
cold and i feel like it was ice cold i
feel like yeah because i was too cold so
like i wasn't heating up at all so it
didn't it didn't help but my feet were
just too cold yeah yeah so like so like
the tactic that i had in my head right
was uh fall asleep before you really
start feeling the cold yeah i do um and
that's that's why we just like before we
went to the tent we just started [ __ ]
downing beers like nobody's business
we're just like all right can we can we
can we down a little bit yeah let's do
it we [ __ ] we [ __ ] need it to
sleep in this weather uh so we after we
down the beers um and i started calling
connor um it worked like i fell asleep
actually pretty fast yeah me too yeah
i've got a good amount of sleep i think
yeah so good quality sleep i felt rough
yeah i i got like a good three four
hours of sleep because i remember waking
up at around 4am and that's that's when
it really started to hit me the [ __ ]
situation i was in right that was like
the minimum what time was your makeup
did you not sleep at all i no no i slept
i probably slept maybe about two or
three hours and then i woke up at like
four yeah around four-ish the same thing
yeah and then i was just like i i can't
i can't i checked the temperatures like
minus six celsius and i was like [ __ ] it
so see yeah i know that if you wake up
and you actually start looking at your
phone and stuff you will wake up yeah
yeah so every time i woke up because i
woke up sporadically throughout the
night i would just immediately force
myself to not do anything and go back to
sleep yeah so i got to sleep until
around 5 56 i think i remember i i just
i got out of the tent i was like i need
to start walking and that point it was
like four or five degrees minus yeah so
i i i got out at like four a.m and with
like all the clothes i had on and i was
just like i'm just gonna go for a walk
because yeah this is the only way i can
i was i was so much colder walking
really yeah because i had to i had the
problem of what happens when you drink
too many beers you need to pee yeah and
so i really really needed the pee yeah
and the toilet was very far away yeah so
i walked to it i bought a coffee from a
vending machine there to heat my hands
up because i was using i paid 100 i paid
a dollar every time i need to heat my
hands up i was so cold i didn't even
give a [ __ ] i didn't drink the coffee
yeah i just used it as a hand warmer
yeah so it was like saving my life it's
like my lifeline
yeah i had gone through like four of
these one dollar coffee just to keep my
hand warm because i was like
[Music]
oh my god it was awful and it was it was
dreadful and i i had to go and pee and
peeing was painful but in this luckily
the one saving grace of this campsite
was at the hotel at a hotel the the
toilet thank god praise japan had a
bidet and bidets have a heated toilet
seat so i sat on this toilet seat for a
good 15 minutes just going
just knowing that my ass was being
warmed gracefully it was amazing one of
my biggest fears when it goes to camping
right is having to pee
after life after everyone's falling
asleep right because i have the smallest
[ __ ] bladder in the world out of the
tent
and like getting out of the tent and uh
waking everyone everyone up um as you're
going out the tent to pee which
sometimes if i'm drinking i need to pee
two or three times i'm just bringing you
adult diapers yeah luckily they're gonna
warm you up yeah honestly honestly i
don't bring an adult yeah
it would serve two things would warm up
my my legs and my low half my body and
uh i wouldn't need to worry about peeing
anymore all right
so i said oh i gotta warm up
i actually remember even before he went
to bed i remember telling these boys
about my irrational fears when it comes
to peeing when i'm camping so
did you always remember this i'm really
stupid
because uh because we were talking about
horror movies before like something to
do with horror movies i can't remember i
was pretty [ __ ] drunk um but anytime
i pee in like the wilderness like every
time i pee in like the wilderness like
like camping or whatever um so you go up
to like a bush or something and it's
like it's like a bush that extends as
far as the eye can see yeah anything can
be [ __ ] hiding in that bush i've seen
enough horror movies to know that
there's a there could be a [ __ ]
monster or [ __ ] jason on the other
side waiting to chop me up there could
be anything so like i have this arrest
what are you five years old
yes joey i'm five years old dexter's
chilling in the bush waiting for you i
could be you know so so like ever since
i was a kid every time i would go up to
pee by myself like i'd hear the boys
just like bantering in the background
and i'd be about like you know 20
20 30 meters away in the dark so they
can't really see me but they know i'm
there so i'm peeing in this bush and i
have this i always have this irrational
fear that something is going to come out
of this bush and like attack me or grab
me or a creature's gonna like [ __ ]
chomp me up or something like that
because that's what happens in every
[ __ ] horror movie it's always like
the guy taking the piss next to the lake
side of the bush that he never expects
he's a bit drunk that's that's when they
die that's when they always die you need
to cut down on the horror movies
i think sydney's making you watch one
yeah
so every time i go b i'm like eagle-eyed
looking for like any [ __ ] movement
every any like any any any [ __ ] shake
of the bush i'm like ready to like leg
it the other way i don't even care if my
dicks are at this point i'm like i'm
like lagging it right
you should be thankful that it was so
cold because if it wasn't that cold i
would have absolutely controlled you no
because
because because it was cold right so
here i am here i am keeping an eagle eye
out of any sign of a possible monster um
that could come out of the bush right um
and then but me being drunk someone like
one of you guys say something funny you
start laughing i look over and i'm just
like huh you know the boys are just
being boys i look back over and i see
something someone's breath just like
just like going towards like a white
cloud yeah like a white cloud i'm like
[ __ ] there's there's a monster hiding in
that bush and then i soon realized
literally half a second in that it's
just my piss steaming
i gave myself
my wrist
my piss gave me like a minute scared
from your pee i
my piss gave me like a mini [ __ ]
heart attack
because i thought there was like a
monster hiding in the bush
so um so yeah that that that already
shows how cold it was even before
uh eve even before we uh started
sleeping so luckily like i i'd held my
piss for as long as i could until like i
woke up yeah and i remember waking up
and i was just you can't get back in
that sleeping bag once you wake up no
it's not possible i gave up no so i
remember waking up and i tried to go
back to sleep um and of course this was
this was the exact moment
that uh connor and nabi decide to have a
snoring contest
yes yes you guys
you guys definitely did it it was oh
like i don't i don't know why they chose
this exact moment right because i'm
waking up why do you think i got my own
tent dude i i like like you can't you
were like four feet away from me
i i remember waking up right i remember
waking up and it was like dead silence
and i remember
i had about i had like a good 10 minutes
of dead silence right and i remember
like i remember like checking my bladder
right to be like do i need to pee no
thank god i don't need to pee thank god
that like my blood is empty enough for
me to be able to go back to sleep yeah
so i like turn over try and try and find
a nice comfortable position and then i
just i just hear i just hear connor next
me going
and then i was just like connor connor
don't don't don't you [ __ ] dare and
then he doesn't do anything more and
then nabi just goes
and i'm just like no no please no i like
i get another five seconds of silence
connor turns over
and i'm just like [ __ ] for [ __ ] sake
i'm trying to i'm trying to get the
blood flowing as much
i do remember that moment actually
because that was around the time where i
decided to wake up and all i could hear
was like what sounded like two like
really old motor boats trying to start
off
[Music]
it was just like a feedback loop like
you just kept feeding into each other
and i'm just like i was like are they
i don't i don't normally snore but when
i have to sleep on my back that's when i
snore also you guys were drinking as
well right yeah yeah yeah
you snore more when you drink but like
that wasn't the only dilemma i had to go
through because um now at this point i
had sobered up a lot more at least a lot
more that i could definitely definitely
feel the [ __ ] cold ride um so i
realized that uh being in a tent you can
warm up your body but the air in the
tent is still cold yeah it is still cold
air um so i was trying to breathe
through my nose and i swear to god every
every breath i took was like freezing
the moisture inside my nose like are you
saying you became a mouth breathing no
yeah yeah like so so like why why why
are these guys
tactics
what are these guys are having a [ __ ]
story contest i'm i'm here trying to
trying to successfully breathe through
my nose without it hurting and after
about five minutes i'm just like
what are you i gotta become
i'm like i've become i'm going to become
the thing i detested i became a mouth
breather but even that like didn't help
like
i i tried breathing through my mouth but
it was still too [ __ ] cold
so i had to like take my i had to take
my jacket off right and try to fashion
this kind of pillow scarf kind of thing
where
my face was being covered right so that
like i had enough air so like so like it
was it was like dune or something yeah
yeah yeah kind of so i i tried to i
tried to masquerade this [ __ ] mask on
me where i had enough i had enough
air um to breathe but it was also
insulating the cold air yeah um that
didn't work because then um if anyone's
tried to sleep with like the blanket
over your head you soon realize that uh
you can't [ __ ] breathe yeah you can't
breathe you're very stuffy yeah you're
gonna get very stuffy you're probably
gonna die of like carbon dioxide
poisoning yeah um so basically i had to
make the choice of trying to sleep um
suffocating myself
or freezing my lungs and uh neither
neither choice sounded like a good
choice to me so here i am for 30 minutes
like i would i would put the cover over
my head try to breathe through it for a
good like 30 minutes doesn't work take
it off find another position it sounds
like you're like one step away from like
just breathing your own farts yeah i
mean that might have honestly been the
best
i would have taken any [ __ ] solution
that worked
um but like eventually me trying to go
to sleep connor eventually wakes up and
he goes out the tent
um and so i try sleeping for another
another like half an hour to 45 minutes
before i just give up and just try going
out and at that point everyone's already
out yeah um so i didn't know what these
guys were doing i thought i thought
connor had like gone for a walk or
something
um i thought you know i thought maybe
they'd gone back to another ten i had no
idea what they're doing because i
remember them talking outside but when i
went outside nobody was there
so
so i i remember um i remembered like
trying to find where everyone was and
then for some reason i just i felt the
car or i heard the car engine like
purring right yeah i'm just like why is
the car on what's going on here and keep
in mind i had contacts on uh before i
slept so i had taken them off so i
couldn't see [ __ ] so i was like trying
to feel my way through everything was
blurry for me um so i go towards the car
and i see connor just [ __ ] sleeping
on the driver's seat
these [ __ ]
had
had gone into the car brain had gone
into the car turned the engine on
and just slept in the [ __ ] car yeah
[ __ ] the camping trip
they had gone back to civilization right
listen i in my mind i'm like listen i've
slept it's 6 00 am it's technically
morning i've awoken now i want to get
warm i'm going to the [ __ ] car
because at that point i was like what do
we actually do i don't know what to do
i can't sit on the toilet for hours
like we're not gonna do we're not gonna
leave for a few more hours yeah and i
was like there's nowhere i can go to get
warm all right
no one can accuse me of not camping i
slept in the tent until six a.m i'm now
going in the car to heat up so i i i
joined him uh obviously yeah turn the
engine on for a bit and then it got hot
enough and then the sun was starting to
come out so we just turned it off yeah
and then we just chilled in the car i
slept like four hours yeah i mean i'm
i'm giving them [ __ ] but the only reason
i'm giving them [ __ ] was because i saw
kind of sleeping in the car i'm just
like
you [ __ ] genius big brain mode i like
exactly i excitedly opened the car door
being like you [ __ ] geniuses and then
i quickly see that all the [ __ ] seats
are taken
so i originally i was like come on joe
let's go in the car i'm gonna go in the
car and i didn't want i didn't want all
this wasted electricity that i'm using
because it's a massive waste of
electricity but the time i was like i'm
gonna die i'm just gonna i'm gonna get
in the car it's minus four [ __ ] this uh
there's people taking photos of fuji
yeah they were dying for their craft and
i salute them but not me i had nothing
to gain from that yeah so i was i'm
getting the car joey come on in and then
and then slowly everyone started trying
to get in the car
because they were also freezing and then
they basically turned into like a sauna
where like people were coming in and out
like just trying to warm up yeah because
like i opened the car door and every
[ __ ] seat was taken and it and like
it wasn't filmed because like i'm glad
it wasn't filmed because it would have
would have quickly turned into like the
salty saltiest moment of trash
because i was like
[ __ ] these guys
[ __ ] these guys [ __ ] them and i went for
a walk trying to figure out how i'm
going to warm myself up it was great
like because the car was slightly on a
hill as well so when i
uh reclined the chair yeah it was
literally like a flat bed yeah yeah and
this one on the aircon which is blasting
does doesn't really do anything for the
first like 10 minutes because the car
wasn't moving yeah so just like what
we're doing yeah so i'm i'm still like
tired as [ __ ] i start walking around i
try taking some nice photos of fuji but
at this point i'm like [ __ ] dying i
couldn't [ __ ] you
i found a way to warm myself up um so
this is this is like me using like 100
of my brain right because i'm an
engineer and what do engineers do we
problem solved right and i did that too
yeah you did i can't believe you're not
problem solving unfortunately i couldn't
go for the same solution because navi
was like fast asleep so i couldn't be
like nabi give me the card get the [ __ ]
out get the [ __ ] out let's go into the
car
so um
so i walk over uh to take the piss you
know to take a piss in the toilet and i
see the vending machine and then
then like the [ __ ] the [ __ ] bulb
just like lights above my head yeah i'm
just like guys i figured this out so i
go back to my tent i get my wallet right
i get my wallets and i just i just start
putting coins in i start buying coffee
because connor huh how many did you buy
i bought like six in there
that sounds more inefficient than using
the car
probably it probably is but i i that
that was the only solution i could come
up with right right why did you not just
jump in the other car we had two cars
it's canned coffees by the way not like
so so to explain we had a vending
machine there and japanese vending
machines have this option where some of
the drinks are warmed right
and that was the only source of heat i
could find in like a five mile radius at
this point right so so here i am like
spending like a hundred yen for like a
coffee which to me i just like i just
like heat packs right yeah i start
packing them into my coat right
at this point i like i i like actually
like start rationing them so i start uh
so i take about six coffees [ __ ] rush
back to the tent go back into my
sleeping bag i like throw throw two cans
at my feet because that's where my feet
my foot were the coldest and the rest i
started like packing in my winter
jackets i pack some some some in my like
bottom pockets some in like my side my
sleeve pockets some of my side pockets
have the best [ __ ] sleep of my life
man
it worked it actually [ __ ] works i
got like i got like some proper air
circulation in this [ __ ] sleeping bag
man
i felt so rough the next day
i slept like 10 hours as well i just
felt awful yeah yeah i think because
there's something about eating like just
meat as well that just makes me feel
awful
yeah i get that and a lot of beers we
didn't have the best diet the night
before so yeah when i just meet like
only me i feel like my body feels like
beaten up like i need some like
something else to help stomach the blow
yeah
so yeah more of the story is um you know
you're more prepared you're much better
don't underestimate the winter yeah i
thought it would be fine who gives a
[ __ ] about what bear grylls says when
you could just get warm coffee that's
the secret that's the secret just get in
the car why do bare girls not go to the
nearest vending machine all you need is
a company just go to a vending machine
just grab a vending machine pack
yourself some warm [ __ ] coffee and
just use that [ __ ] warm yourself up i
don't know why russians are complaining
like i've seen siberian winters
just need a vending machine
their car engines freeze